des véhicules en feu des bâtiments
détruits et des civils extirpé des
décombres
cette semaine les populations ont fait
les frais de l'intensification des
combats au haut karabagh comme ici à
gandja la deuxième plus grosse ville
d'azerbaidjan ou à stepanakert capitale
de la région séparatiste
ce dimanche le bilan officiel fait état
d'une quarantaine de civils tués
mais la violence des combats et les
moyens employés laisse craindre un bilan
bien plus élevé des populations civiles
qui selon les deux camps seraient
volontairement visé par l'artillerie
adverse
les forces armées arméniennes ont
utilisé des bombes à fragmentation
interdites par les conventions
internationales
ces dernières sont notamment utilisés
dans les systèmes de lance-roquettes
smerch et vise les villes d'azerbaïdjan
l'ennemi continue de violer toutes les
lois écrites et non écrite de la guerre
frappant les régions habitées au plus
profond des lignes arrières actuellement
ces zones civiles sont sous les tirs
d'artillerie notamment les rockets qui
cible les civils de la capitale
stepanakert des victimes civiles
déploraient dans chaque camp est
confirmé par les ong sur place puisque
nous sommes présents des deux côtés de
la ligne de contact
nous avons été en mesure d'évaluer les
conséquences humanitaires qui incluent
entre autres des blessures et des décès
de civils y compris d'enfants signalés
des deux côtés de la ligne de contact
ainsi qu'en arménie nous avons reçu en
outre de nombreux rapports sur des
infrastructures civiles détruites
notamment des écoles et des hôpitaux et
ce des deux côtés de la ligne de contact
fort knox
une situation qui suscite toujours des
réactions internationales
plusieurs manifestations pro arménienne
se sont déroulés ces derniers jours
comme ici aux etats unis
en grèce ou encore en france l'hexagone
où plus de cent soixante dix élus dont
anne hidalgo laurent wauquiez ou bernard
cazeneuve ont signé ce week-end une
tribune dans le journal du dimanche
demandant à paris de prendre position
dans ce conflit aux côtés des revan nous
considérons que la diplomatie française
doit réexaminer sa stratégie dans le
conflit du haut karabagh dénoncé avec
force l'agression azerbaïdjanaise et
exigé l'arrêt immédiat des violences de
la part de l'azerbaïdjan sous peine d'un
soutien massif aux autorités du haut
karabagh qui passera par la
reconnaissance de leur légitimité pleine
et entière
la france qui a également demandé
vendredi des explications à la turquie
après la découverte dans le
haut-karabagh de la présence de
mercenaires syrien envoyé par ankara
aux côtés des forces azéries les
prémices de l'internationalisation de ce
conflit régional